hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to blood wash wash blood
from your face and hands and clothes
apparently anyway this game in its
description had one of the most stomach
churning names for a
villain i've seen and it's
womb um
and i didn't even have like a womb but
that just makes me go
yeah it's like if there was like the
scrote eviscerator if that was the name
of the person coming after me i would be
i'd be scared and disgusted
i'm probably mostly scared
oh oh
all right
what a day
professor watt was his usual miserable
self and that test was a killer
hopefully i can just relax i bet you
can't
of course
liam didn't do the laundry or clean
i'll have to do a load of laundry
i have an interview for a job tomorrow
and have nothing to wear
huh i'll gather these clothes up and
head to the laundry room in the basement
i'm going to have to talk to liam leader
i'm too upset and tired to go through it
again
he's going to have to pull it together
for this baby
that was a lot of backstory all at once
but also it's more backstory than i've
ever forgotten in a horror game which is
kind of good
very close
damn you liam
who put clothes in the actually you know
what i shouldn't say anything because
i've
i've definitely left clothes exactly
where they lay in the kitchen
i am liam i went shopping last week so
it's pretty full right now
i'm ashamed to say i've started to rely
on soda to keep me up through the day
nothing interesting inside i'm saving up
for a vacuum so i can clean this place
properly
no one i should call especially at this
hour i still haven't had time to unpack
yet not sure when i will
yeah liam
i'm honestly too mad to talk to liam
right now let him get over his hangover
by himself oh how do you know he's in
there okay i'll get this place cleaned
up womp womp or i think it's all the
dirty laundry time to go to the basement
man i hate this thing i have cricks in
my body i didn't even know it was
possible
filled with pencils and half written
research papers
well we live like kings here don't we
mostly my psych books i must have read
each of these at least twice
okay i'll go down to the basement which
i'm sure is going to go good for me
hello
that's weird a nice man lives here it's
good to know you have at least one good
neighbor
and i'm betting this is a
there's a [ __ ] bag over here womb ripper
strikes again
in the early hours of the 30th
authorities were called though in a
passerby found a terribly mangled corpse
haphazardly tossed on the nearby grounds
sources indicate that the woman was
indeed pregnant and just like previous
victims the fetus was cut out and
assumed to be taken by the assailant
this is now the fourth victim in as many
weeks and authorities are struggling to
come up with leads in one of the most
gruesome crime sprees this city has ever
endured
good
god a woman and a son live here now that
i think about it i haven't seen either
one in about a week
oh
well good thing i'm uh
pregnant surprised they take any safety
precautions in this death trap yep
oh this is good well this is a good
thing
i don't need to go to that floor besides
one of the people on this floor as a
mean dog they keep in the hall who keeps
it in the hall
all right
i don't need to go through there okay
where is this laundry room yeah
oh boy
i love the breathing
i love the size and the breathing it's
like this basement
specifically travels the acoustics of
everyone's breathing in their apartments
down here
and exposed to electrical boss nice
let's see what's inside rad droppings
trash and spiders
great this one feels empty i feel that's
best case scenario filled with horn
porno rags might be worth a penny or two
if they weren't drenched in dubious
stains
oh oh why is this game gotta be gross
toolbox our janitor would kill me if i
promise through his things even though i
really doubt he uses any of these smells
like it hasn't been taken out for months
and that door doesn't exist
what out of order what am i gonna do now
i should probably go back upstairs and
figure something out
i think i heard something coming from
that
no you didn't
no no you didn't
do i have to do i have to ah
okay hi
joe
i scared you oh you scared me oh
all right you both scared me what the
hell are you doing creeping around down
here well yeah what are you doing look
i'm sorry for scaring you i'll tell you
but can you keep this to yourself uh-huh
yeah i can what's up
uh mrs kicked me out and it's too cold
outside so i'm trying to wait her out
down here i really didn't mean to creep
on you honest
uh-huh i believe you just next time
maybe don't go around slinging doors
open and hiding in the dark yeah maybe
that i will thanks kid
say if you want to use the washing
machine it's uh broken yeah thanks i
figured that out
thanks hobo joe thanks hobo joe
thanks so when okay i didn't read hobo
joe when it when it like suddenly jumped
open i read hand job and i'm like what
do i got to do what am i doing right now
all right anyway what are you doing in
this closet what are you doing again for
scaring you kiddo god damn you're tall
it's okay
all right bye
you keep t posing in there you have a
good day now have a good day
been a while since i've been hit with a
classic jump scare like that
classic
all right then is there no like front
door to this building
and now that it dawns on me i don't
remember seeing anything
hi
hello does everyone love to stand
ominously in doorways hey
good god
[Music]
yeah the way your head's turning what's
up sarah oh hi oh you know trying to
balance life school and job hunting
mm-hmm yep it's a tough world these days
liam been treating you well
when he isn't drunk
yeah no that's so sad
you tell me if it gets bad
yeah
i know it ain't easy to talk about
and you don't have to tell me nothing
just promise me you'll tell me if you
need help oh thanks stan my sister used
to be in a bad situation too and there's
places you can go i appreciate that stan
i really do
yeah sure
you doing some laundry at this time of
night i'm trying to
of course when i really need it the
washer downstairs is broken
ain't that some [ __ ]
yeah
and speaking of [ __ ] i have an interview
tomorrow so i guess i'll show up
smelling like crap
well if it's an emergency i heard this
laundromat that's open 24 7. just
outside of town still early enough to
catch the last bus
i have to say though
it's a hell of a time to be out so late
especially with that maniac roaming
around i'm a big girl stan
do you know the address sure sure let me
write it down for you just promise me
you'll take care i
i promise
i better go grab my purse i promise stan
hurry and you might be able to catch the
next bus okay once again stan what about
the bus back is it still does it still
go back by the way love the sweater
i don't like that head turn but i love
the sweater
liam you [ __ ]
oh there's my purse
all right hopefully i didn't miss that
last bus to the laundromat
all right liam all right liam i think i
made my point
bye
you might be thanks again thanks again
stan
goodbye where do i go maybe first floor
is the way um
again
[Music]
hi how you doing
hi there
are you okay
can i get you anything
it's gone
they they took it
did someone steal something from you huh
they took it the people in the walls
they
took it from me
oh god she's here now
i should probably leave him alone poor
guy who's here now
the people in the walls
who's in the walls
okay goodbye all right have fun whoa
man nights pretty scary here
oh hi
got any change sure i have a couple
dollars
better than nothing thanks kid i haven't
seen you around here before
i moved in not too long ago i'm usually
studying at my classes so that's
probably why
oh a college girl huh
what are you studying i'm pursuing a
career in education at the moment
nice that's what i got my bachelor's in
oh
that's great
i hope i can find a gig soon afterwards
if not my sleeping bag has room for two
ah
okay
all right thank you for the offer
oh great hey
oh boy
hello
how are you
don't mind me
just waiting for the bus
enter bus
i'm on the hi where are you heading at
this hour if you don't mind me asking
that's pretty ominous but uh the
laundromat on the outside of town
not sure i believe that
pretty late to be doing laundry hey if
you're looking to score i have a good
deal just for a pretty little thing like
you
how about you just drive the bus and
i'll pretend you're not a desperate
loser whatever [ __ ] set the [ __ ] down
so i can get this piece of junk rolling
again
all right thanks man a dirty seat dirty
seat is there a clean seat oh they're
all dirty aren't they
oh
oh polaroid
has to be fake some people have a sick
sense of humor
well i guess i'll i'd rather not sit
in whatever is splattered on that seat
well
i mean there's real ah here we go
hmm
so the weather's nice
i like when it's a temperature outside
you ever seen a cloud
oh
hello
you're just uh standing there buddy
oh
hi wow aren't you looking fancy
uh
all right
okay pepperoni eyeball man oh
hi
yes hi hello
okay
it's so dark i can't even see this
oh my god oh my god hello may i sit
beside you now there's plenty of other
seats so i don't see why you would need
to do that may
i may i sit beside you no
do i need to get the driver to throw you
off you're going to die tonight that's
pretty good
you're going to die tonight
i've seen it
tonight is your last night on earth okay
you are walking straight into your doom
can't you see that
you and that child inside you okay
you will be
found just like all the others ripped
open your insides displayed for all the
angels above to look down and see
oh yes
of that i am certain great
do your
do you have pepperoni nipples to match
your eyeballs
please just stop talking may i sit
beside you
no all right miss this is your stop
it
may ice
no
weirdo
it's easy to see someone's future of
death and murder if you're the one death
murdering me
i love the name of the company's torture
star video great
look at priest and jordan king and henry
oh
great
pretty dope i mean honestly this is a
more involved game than i thought it was
it's pretty impressive
damn whoa
dude this game is way more involved than
i thought it was
wait what the hell i thought this is
just like a one-off short demo game like
most horror games i play i didn't know
that this was fully involved this is
dope as hell
this is dope as hell
okay hello
here i am
that's what i
think it says
hi okay slint
[Music]
something coming after me or what is the
deal
it's here fine
probably nothing to worry about okay i
see pizza appliances i'm guessing this
is london
spin cycle laundromat okay
hey
how you doing lost and found
whoa press the tab to a oh okay i'll
bring it back before i leave it'll be a
long night so i might need it okay yes
what is it
oh um
are you all really open all night we're
open all night but i take my naps at
midnight so you better not need anything
after that
okay man
okay
i'll be sure not to need anything look
at that face
yeah we'll see
we'll see yeah we'll see i'm gonna wake
you up i'm gonna wake you up so many
times okay all right then i'll do my
laundry do i need some change um
the only person i have to call is still
probably throwing up in the bathroom
wait didn't even know they're thrown up
remote ooh
hey friend i like freaking late night
wash too
yeah
i work night shift at the factory down
the road
this place is the only one open when i
get off work
was a real pain when the first one burnt
down
the what first one
you do around here
yeah this place used to be next door
years ago but there was a big fire
i don't think they ever found out
exactly what caused no one ever mentions
a fire and it's just like a casual
one-off thing it's always a horrendous
problem that like is related to the
entirety of the crux of the issue here
so
i'm just assuming that's important girl
died in that fire too
an employee
i don't like to spread rumors but
but what but what
pretty mysterious
the way she died i mean it wasn't a fire
that started quickly she should have had
plenty of time to get out but she was
found in the office
sleeping i heard they were close to
opening up a murder investigation
that a detective thought the girl was
locked in but then decided to drop it
when nobody came up hmm you know cops
lazy sons of i know
that's true it does sound pretty suspect
interesting sure does sure does feels
like it got swept under the rug pretty
quick what with the womb ripper coming
around and butchering those women
that has all the headlines these days
hmm
okay cool well thanks for the uh
thanks for the backstory oh
i need to get some change first i knew i
did i know how this all works whoa what
is that all about this wall looks
different from the others yeah you're
damn righted dude
why is the change machine back here
why
all right that should be enough for a
washing or dry cycle why is it all the
way back here
why would it be all the way back there
you still there buddy boo okay good
urban legends won
urban legends ooh
whoa it's a comic what the hell
all right well
this is probably uh important
information
[Music]
okay cool oh no
well that's fun okay anyway i gotta wash
guess i can take a look at the other
stores in the plaza while i wait for my
clothes i guess i can
i guess i can
i'm gonna do that hey where'd the
employee go
dang
i need
assistance all right fine i guess he's
taking his nap which is no problem for
me
i didn't hear anything what are you
talking about sounds like a child crying
but i don't think it's a kid yeah no i
don't think so either
i don't think so yeah no i i i don't
think so
people peoples
people
hey people help you
looking for anything specific
a movie movie a video game oh you know
you know
fish um no just browsing things i choose
fish let me know if you need any help
all right p-paw and don't you even think
about stealing anything i have eyes
everywhere okay i'm gonna take that
literally wouldn't dream of it
you have quite an assortment of things
what kind of store is this again hmm
it's pee pals
i'm peepal
it's my store
okay
right all right cool horror movies i
could read the back of these all day for
the residents of holloway senior care
center dying in your sleep is the best
thing that can happen classic
vinyl records
oh
wow why
whoa too bad liam won't do any of the
things the guys doing these tapes do or
the girls
what
huh
what's next virtual reality right of
course
see smile i'm on camera
interesting interesting interesting
the interesting
what the hell
gotcha
uh
you're not stealing anything no i'm not
damn my apologies
okay all right i got nothing to say
about that all right we'll see or see
around
shotgun
her name is shotgun and she has a
all right cool
the master system is out now but this is
still my favorite
i already have one it's been great to
have since i'm really home these days
everyone is followed by something
hopefully for me it's not that creep
from the bus
fish
you do have fish
wow what did i just get
interesting
huh
who made these comics what made them
well i can't show this one oh get out of
here
very interesting
huh okay well
thanks p-paw i'm gonna leave now later
p-paw
exit pawn shop no that was p-paws
that wasn't a pawn shop what are you
talking about what are you talking about
eggs at a pawn shop this is pea paws
oh
it's an old shirt does it have blood i
don't really want to inspect it any
further i guess it could be something
else
what
smells like spoiled meat gross
oh four five one oh four five one
everyone to remember oh four five one oh
four five one
oh four five one everybody oh four five
one
oh four five one
remember write in the comments oh four
five one help me remember if you all
write in the comments i might actually
remember it oh four five one
i've forgotten it already
okay pizza parlor
hey visa
oh nice place you got here
missing person flyer that is a young
woman list missing over a week there's
so many different ones i wonder if
anyone around here knows anything about
this i can bring this to people and see
if they have anything to say about it
all right
duly noted if a good night's sleep isn't
in my future then i don't want to hear
about it oh
is that my dick out is my dick out is my
dick out and swinging do i have a
swinging dick out
am i swinging dick out
wham
bam you're a capitalistic casualty
all right fair enough hey you know
anything do you know anything about the
recent disappearances um no not really
one of the girls who was in my class was
one of them though oh so you do know
something i didn't know her too well
except that she was pregnant
i hope that she just skipped down and
not one of the you know
victims
yeah okay all right let me go ask
pee-paw
pee-paw do you know anything about the
recent disappearances recent recess this
has been going on for a long
time uh-huh how long
like
when the womb ripper killings first
began
lord no i'm talking years girl
years
don't make me repeat myself
yes this area
hasn't been the safest place
not since that laundromat caught fire
the one over there
no that's the new one
the old one is right next to it
been empty ever since that night well i
don't like that are you saying there's
some correlation between the laundromat
fire
and the missing people
i'm just saying what i'm saying hmm all
right well i'm saying what i say which
is words anything else you can tell me
ah leave an old man b i have things to
attend to do you do you pee paul do you
do you have things to attend to and what
is that actually smells pretty good like
the drowned and butter movie theater
popcorn i would like some of that i'm
kind of hungry all right anyway bye
people
or is it a pawn shop
which is it people
okay so what's the deal about this
i wonder what happened here uh a fire
weren't you paying attention to anything
yeah you're stupid and also that means
that hole in the wall goes to this
interesting is my laundry done what are
you a cop or something i don't know
anything about those missing people
sorry
okay all right then
well time to hit the old dusty trail oh
it's done whoa handy that
all right let's dry your time
bam
topper in
it's entering the belt the front counter
hello
am i supposed to go in the bath is this
like an invitation or something should i
not take this
i don't feel like i should take this
locked weird well good thing i have a
key
interesting
condoms no damn buns great
ow
oh
8675309
interesting
i don't like it
hmm
that's loud
huh
this is for public intoxication but that
name keeps popping up wonder if i can
find out more about them i can bring
this to people and see if they have
anything to say about it oh
sorry
okay bye
don't like that
the hell
is that a mannequin
with a baby
who could have put this here yeah who
could have put that there
okay sgp
173. well you got me
you got me
well done you got me
what the hell
what
an ugly doll head
what i don't remember seeing that on my
wind yeah i don't remember seeing it
either
hello don't know how you got that but
yeah i knew louis
he owned the old laundromat that burnt
down
we were buds
but he disappeared one day we were buds
yeah okay it's the aliens i tell ya
lewis is looking down on us poor
schmucks right now from the cosmos
uh-huh okay all right you believe that
is my laundry done can i go home now
six minutes and 52 seconds left oh it's
actually a timer oh interesting okay
well i've
okay well i already
found everything i needed
unless there's some way to
break through here
maybe i guess we're just waiting then
what
okay
that's strange i could've sworn i've
seen this car before
i did didn't i is that one that was
waiting for me
or on the other side of the street
before the bus came
four minutes and three seconds left
well i guess i could play a
game
pork skis revenge
oh
[Music]
i am really getting revenge i don't know
what caused this rebellion but i'm
murdering what looks like
children
so that's a thing that i have now
on my soul
kind of a bop though
[Music]
oh wait did it restart wait
what did that happen did i fail i don't
know i was bopping out
yeah one minute 22 all right i'll be
right back then
in one minute and 22 seconds
goodbye
is it done
did anything spooky happen while i was
away
18 seconds left
we're almost done and then we go home
and then we're completely free to go
home
oh that mannequin still there i don't
like it
what the hell
clothes are still wet
this machine must be broken but those
are my last quarters i need to find that
employee and get my quarters back hey
employee oh
oh
well that's not good hello
oh hi oh my god it's the employee what
happened did he fall for all these
shreds
i need to call the police i sure do i
sure do
this might come in handy now
give me that hammer
looks like uh looks like uh
looks like i'm gonna get my money back
because if i would know the code i might
know the code
is it oh four five one
because you guys help me remember it
it might be that
okay
what's your emergency um
hello sarah you need to send someone now
i'm at the
hello
[ __ ] sheet
you [ __ ]
20 minutes oh
wait how did they get here dispatch said
they got a call coming from out here
but it's strange uh
why i can't seem to be able to find
anyone
oh i'm the cop now
oh i'm policeman john
or officer burton officer burton here
pizza's closed people's clothes plants
closed
wait a minute
[Music]
income tax
it's the income baby it sounds like it's
coming from that office by the pizza
place goddamn tax babies
all right i'll go to the tax baby
goddamn babies all right okay all right
okay all right bring it on baby i can i
can i can fight a baby hello
is anyone there is anyone here the
police this is the police if anyone is
there then come out now if you're a baby
and you don't come out with your hands
up i'ma shoot wildly
recklessly even
something wrong here
i better investigate them i better
investigate thoroughly
note that donna reads whoever's eating
my lunches i will find out who you are
and report you to henry
poor donna poor donna
anybody uh babies schedule request
doesn't look suspicious to me
looks like a business plan of some sort
okay
expense reports nothing important wookie
believe it or not i don't have to make
copies right now
it's empty hello
not a fire marshal okay
babies
nothing jumps out to me nothing jumps
out to me or does it some kind of filing
cabinet that stores files of some sort
who's in here
what the frick
[Music]
crumpled piece of paper that i'm too
lazy to unfold wow really way to go aha
would you look at that a confession in
this email from ben saying that he has
been eating donna's lunch another case
solved you bastard
all right
clock it's lying about the time but i
guess i can't bring it in for that
backrooms damn door's stuck god damn it
i'm in the back rooms god
damn it all right well i'm here forever
now
i'm here forever
i'm here for goddamn forever aren't they
i'm stuck in the oh my god i'm stuck
maybe i can find a key around here
somewhere
what
hello
what what what
are your hands up or down i don't care
put everything down no don't you dare
the [ __ ]
what's that what in the [ __ ] was that
holy jesus
was it holding a
child i don't know you're the cop here
bang okay
bang bang bang unlimited ammo baby
[Music]
get on the ground
okay
this is my 968
shot revolver
bang
seems like it doesn't fit this story you
know what does fit this door bang
bang boom bang bang bao bao bao
ba bang bang boom bang boom bang
who's down he's always how many babies
do i got carve my way through to victory
okay
put your hands on the ground
put your ass on the ground and your
hands in the air
get your ass on the ground
i hate it i hate it i hate it the answer
is i hate it
oh god no
i'm gonna kill you
[Music]
oh my god am i glad to see you oh i
almost shot you you gotta help me
there's some crazy person running around
with a knife okay slow down it's okay
just follow me and i'll get you out of
here
i might
whoa bang boom bang bang bang bang i got
him okay
bang
okay bang this is where i would shoot
this is where i am currently shooting
[ __ ]
there has to be another way out of here
yeah
blasting my way out guns blazing i
choose the guns blazing path okay all
right there's got to be another way you
know they're funny as funnily enough
there might just be
seem pretty calm for watching that guy
just get murdered
i'll kill you i'll kill you okay i'm
going in
i'll kill
you i'll kill you
kill you all right
dead all right
what
you can't you can't you won't you shan't
you shouldn't try
who can play at that game [ __ ]
i'm happy [ __ ]
one of us is going to hit the other
eventually
all right fine
looks like i'm out of here
whoa bang bang bang what
i got mortalized
oh god okay oh wow
well i just witnessed that
oh locked oh good i'm so
oh
okay
great
it's a receipt for a building repair
company looks like they had to repair
one of the walls in this laundromat with
plaster i bet i know which one and i bet
i have to hit it with a hammer oh boy
oh boy
is my laundry done
oh wow
[Music]
you're bad at
singing just so you know
very bad
there's a door behind here
i go to old laundry man now
wow
well i don't like any of this
good thing i have a hammer
hi
how you doing
good to see you
oh
shove it stop it now
stop it right there can't open it's
firmly nailed shut oh finally i had a
hammer if only i had a hammer main
suspect in police investigation
disappears good 45 year old lewis
kennedy has gone missing the top suspect
in the grisly crime of arson and alleged
kidnapping murder of a young woman has
eluded authorities sources say that
kennedy has been under surveillance for
a few weeks and at some time over the
course of the last night had broken
contact with officers and has not been
seen since authorities issued a warning
for all residents in the area to be on
the lookout for this potentially
dangerous individual
okay thank you
thank you for that
for that update that must be years old
by now in this old ass laundromat
oh god oh i found the layer
great
good
great hmm what are these doing here i
should probably leave yeah i shouldn't
be here yeah i
i definitely shouldn't be here oh no not
a flashlight where is it where is it
where is it where is it where is it
where is my goddamn flashlight oh i
don't it's not actually a thing this is
just gonna turn on
[Applause]
get in the freezer
get in the cabinet whoa whoa get in the
crates oh get in the crate oh get in the
barrel i i don't know i guess i go this
way won't budge
oh what the hell when did that happen
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh my god
i run i run so many knobs and so little
knowledge
i'm i'm i'm liable to blow myself up
yeah can i crouch is there any how do i
crouch can i crouch
i can't crouch i've never known crouch
oh i didn't need to crouch who's
above my head
hey pal you okay so corpse looks like
it's been here for a very long time okay
flesh oh my god oh my god
how long have i been here last thing i
remember was walking home and now i'm
locked in this godforsaken room who
would do this to me and why i need to
find a way to get out here let's drive
blood on the walls and floor and i have
my child to think about now
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yep
yeah oh yeah
i know i won't be getting out of here
alive that's psychopathic it kills women
like me i've heard at least three others
brought here and killed peeking through
the cracks i saw that it creates these
masks out of skin skin from the poor
infants whose mothers were just
slaughtered
i don't know what kind of game it's
wanting to play i think my time is
almost up it made me swallow key a key
that i think would get me out of here
but i have a feeling it won't let me
live long enough to use it i'll be
strung up and butchered like the rest of
my baby oh god i'm sorry my little angel
oh
my god those were faces oh i know why
you gave me the scalpel i know why
and i am not going to hesitate
look i got my baby to worry about
and and like i i i do not have time to
ask gimme gimme key i can believe i'm
doing this me and my baby we're getting
out of here live and also i'm going to
stab this in the eye or whatever freak
wants to try to cut my baby out of me
screw you in everything you have about
get your ass out of my ass get asked out
ass ass kill you i'll kill you so hard
i'll kill you
i'll kill i'll kill you
i'll kill you i'll kill you okay seems
like you've already been killed
it's
a corpse
it looks like it's been here for years
there's a wallet sticking out of his
pocket kennedy what
the driver's license belongs to lewis
kennedy but this doesn't make any sense
i need to get out of here and call the
police
yeah i've been trying i've been i've
been really trying i'll kill you i'll
kill you i'll kill you i'll kill you
i'll kill you oh my god oh my god
this plate open looks like she hasn't
been here very long oh my god
i'll kill you i'll freak i'll kill you
i'll kill you i'll kill you i'll kill
you
i didn't think that this place was so
big on the outside it seems like way
bigger right now for some reason find
the child
okay
is this person just playing a game with
me is that what's going on here i feel
like that's what's going on i'll kill
you
i'll kill you
i'll freaking kill you
what is this what is what is all this
what is this supposed to be huh
stab you in the teeth i'll stab you in
the teeth
i'll step in that teeth hi
hello
ammo
it's a doll that's been cut in half ammo
i did did i get a gun am i gonna get a
gun okay
i'll kill ya
all right
okay
i'll kill you
don't mess with me oh pistol oh i know
whose arm that is okay yeah all right
i'll frickin kill ya i'm gonna kill you
this doesn't make any sense
what
in the hell
what in the heck in
hell what
i'll freaking kill you
i'm gonna kill you
i'm gonna kill you here we go
bang oh yeah get out of my way
kill you
okay
come out you [ __ ] yeah come on ready
for you okay i'm glad that me and sarah
are on the same page here i'm gonna
freaking kill you i'm gonna kill you
bam
all right that wasn't you kill you
i'm gonna
blow a hole in your brain
i'm gonna blow a hole through your teeth
and out your ass
i'm gonna kill you
don't you
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah you better run yeah you better run
[ __ ] yeah you better run
oh poor baby got a few more whiny holes
baby you
come on you want some more huh i got
plenty i got unlimited
this is a special gun
i got it for beating a resident evil
game straight up unlimited ammo
forever bang get out of my face
hello
oh
sorry
got you got you oh i got you oh you
think you think you think you think you
think
it ain't happening
yeah you cry
[Applause]
yeah you keep crying you keep crying
trash baby trash you trash
you trash you're trash
you trash you coming after me you trash
you're garbage
huh
me try me
try me yeah that's right get out of here
[Applause]
wow that's really pathetic man that's
really pathetic
that's quite pathetic it's quite pitiful
all right i don't know where i'm going
i don't know where i'm going
come on
oh
no
come on
come on hit me
had me
did i loop around
have i been looping did i loop did i
just loop did i loop through the goddamn
hole plate oh my god i did
wow okay so it's a big loop try me
try me you can't you won't you [ __ ] you
shouldn't
try me
oh look at that oh look at that you're
dead
that's right
i don't think i'm not going to shoot you
multiple times
does it what what lewis kennedy wasn't
killing all those women what
who's
who
what
it was samantha oh
after lewis locked from the laundromat
and burned it down
she survived
and she must have lost her baby though
with almost being killed losing her
child and being terribly burned
she completely snapped oh
she killed louis
and then
set her sights on killing others who had
something she didn't oh god
well
[Music]
that was great
that was great i love that that was well
done
i liked that
i liked that a lot had like exploration
to it had a good few good scares here
the final confrontation i actually felt
like man
you i'm gonna freaking kill you you're
not gonna get me my baby not my baby way
to go sarah way to go stan
uh
not so much way to go creepy guy
we're gonna go
hobo joe junkie way to go man with
bachelors way to go bus driver we're
gonna appliance manager we're gonna go
p-paw we're gonna go laundromat employee
way to go patreon way to go call girl
call girl
who's call girl when was there a call
girl oh you know what i bet it was i
didn't actually go up to the numbers on
the wall and like click on them or
something so i bet if i'd uh oh
i bet if i had clicked on them i could
have gone to the phone and actually
called it
oh no
oh no i'm the autopsy attrition well i
was pretty upset to be woken up so late
for an impromptu autopsy but when they
told me that it was the actual womb
ripper
well i got down here as soon as i could
all right doug get ready to get your
work you can't believe that it turned
out to be samantha rhodes who'd gone
missing and was presumed dead years ago
hmm who knew who knew pizza well la la
la i'm not even gonna look at the body
multiple gunshot wounds that's the
official cause of death but jesus christ
i didn't even understand how she was
alive in the first place let alone how
it took so many shots to bring her down
most of those looked fatal on first
glimpse to me i guess we'll dig in and
find out more
oh yeah let's dig in time to dig in
oh
what the hell the power went out well
that's you love to see it the fuse box
is down the hall i'll be right back
don't you go anywhere ha ha hehehe
all right goodbye
this is great
this is great this is great this is
great this is great this is great it's
great it's great it's great it's great
that's fine i have nothing to say about
that i'm doug that happens all the time
okay lights are back on yay
everything's fine
everything's great
uh oh
what the she's gone
i have to get out of here you have to
get is that
how do you know why is it why
i gotta get out of here
[Applause]
i guess i'm
dead but i guess that the womb ripper is
not i love that that was great fantastic
fantastic fantastic really didn't enjoy
that keep making stuff like this is
super fun if you guys want to play this
for yourself link is in the description
go send the developer some love and just
really fun time yeah make more cool
stuff like this if you guys got any more
suggestions for video games like this
that are intricate and well made horror
games that are a complete story i want
to find them i want to play them this
was a surprise so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to see
more scare games that i've done check
the link in the description below thank
you again and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you